[Musique]
c'est parce qu'on peut avoir dans les
prochaines les prochaines années parce
que les maladies
ça ne se libère pour moi je sens une
valse à la retraite
alors comme ça tu as nous instruit au
plus tard cela des maladies ne seront
pas la réveiller thibaut pinot tous les
mois passent et on a des fois on a décru
ces momies aksil tamponnais toute
souriante savent que vieillir est
universel est parmi les maladies les
plus dégénératif se trouve alzheimer
nous tous nous avons vieilli mais c'est
ce que nous pouvons vivre très longtemps
aujourd'hui nous voulons gia en autonome
des parents de la réunion à kuban la
prise en charge au niveau des
établissements les épaules
je veux remercier le maire que bientôt
ici même au temps vont nous allons
inaugurer un départ avec un certain
nombre de places soit sembla offerts
pour tous ceux qui sont en perte
d'autonomie qui vont payer les aidants
familiaux
parce que les aidants bhar cite
également aux vielles mêlée du tampon
collectivité départementale partenaires
associatifs et communauté médicale se
sont unis pour proposer un site de
prévention et d'accompagnement de
connaissances et maternelle gilbert
lessard assisté par fusion étudier la
question et je lui en suis contre
palissy personnes atteintes de maladies
cim et leur famille à l'abandon
il sera à leur charge et la personne
malade et notre part et ne pas permettre
à la personne malade elle même de
trouver un lieu de flickr avec israël me
retenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'équipe maison jaune plein de vie ou
personnes âgées malades mais aussi
aidants familiaux pourrons ensemble
préparer quotidiennement un avenir
meilleur tant qu'il ya deux façons
d'appréhender les sols le vieillissement
en famille avec son identité
comment continuer à manger on aime à
venger le bon produit à bien s'alimenter
comment continuer à se sentir heureux
heureux dans sa commune en ce temps bien
que le champ d'action communale et
social que le département de la réunion
nous accompagne la caisse générale de
sécurité sociale la draft tous ses
partenaires doivent bien travailler
ensemble pour mettre de la cohérence
dans les politiques pour prévenir le
vieillissement et gardez-les avec 1862
bénéficiaires de l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie sur le tampon
sur 12 1963 sur toute l'île cette
réponse des proximités devrait
rapidement faire des émules
[Musique]